Hello 大家好，这里是山河作用。我是Sophie。我是三三。
之前我们有一期就是山神会惩罚每一个乱扔垃圾的人。
对，然后我们今天请来了一个正面人物，就是在山里捡垃圾的人。
对，就是感觉保护环境，然后别扔垃圾这个话题真的是常说常心啊。
是的，然后前两天就是又在听友群大家开启了这个话题的讨论。
有一个内地的旅友，然后在卖里耗尽，然后乱扔垃圾，还上了新闻。
主要是他的态度非常让人讨厌，就是已经有警察对他罚款了，他有他就摆出一副啊无所谓你罚我你罚我我你罚了我钱我就可以扔了，就是这种态度让人看了非常的火大。
所以这个话题呢，我觉得大家也都挺有感触的。
所以我们这次请墓匠来跟我们仔细的聊一下，到底在户外乱扔垃圾会产生什么样的危害，然后以及包括我们能够力损能迹做什么。
墓匠是守护自然的创始人，守护自然是一个在户外组织过很多次晋山活动的一个公益组织。
Hello，墓匠欢迎你来山河作用，觉得一开始要不然你先简单介绍一下自己吧。
Hello，大家好，我是墓匠来自云南九年后，职业是一名马龙程序员，写代码的。
对对对，这个我其实有点没想到啊，其实跟你接下来我们要介绍的另外一个身份的话，感觉稍微有一点差距。
因为马龙感觉就是很宅，天天坐在办公室前面写代码的那种。
所以我觉得你要不先再介绍一下你的另外一个身份，是这个幻魔组织。
守护自然的发起人，我觉得很多可能喜欢户外或者关注户外的朋友，没准在社交媒体上刷到过你那个组织。
但守护自然是手是那个双手的那个手。
对对对，我其实好几年前的时候就已经关注到这个组织了嘛，那时候我们俩加上微信是因为我当时给一个杂志转稿，所以当时约了你采访来着。
终于今天我们自己的这个播客也能邀请到你来一起聊一聊户外的这些剪垃圾的故事。
我觉得挺好的，所以你要不给大家简单介绍一下守护自然，你发起和现在它发展的一个过程。
守护自然是2020年10月份的时候吧，开始的第一次活动，然后现在的话也大概有五年都快六年的时间了。
然后目前的这个形势还是跟以前一样的，都是周末的时候，然后组织大家去山里面去清理垃圾，通过这种就是比较简单粗暴的方式吧，去保护一下这个。
现在这些突破路线的环境，这个活动主要是在哪儿开展呢，之前一直是在北京啊，都是从北京出发，然后路线的话，北京。
天津，然后河北，主要是这三个地方，然后去年11月份我们开始在厂商这边也做了一个小分队，然后现在厂商这边也有这个检视活动。
那你们有计算过比如说开展过多少次活动，比如说减到了多少吨的垃圾这种数据有吗？
有的，我们到现在一共有一百多期活动，然后减在垃圾12吨左右吧。
12吨是个什么概念？
如果按这个就是公开的这种数据，算人均每天产生的垃圾的话，大概是一个人几十年产生的垃圾，生活垃圾量。
就我们平常的认知来讲，马农应该平常就是一个工作很忙碌，然后经常加班的这么一个职业，很宅，对，对，对，而且平常不工作的时候可能就是搭带游戏啊，或者怎么样。
但是你是怎么在日常工作的身份之外还有这么一种身份，而且是挤出时间来把另外这个身份做得如此精彩，对。
就是因为我从小也是在农村长大的，然后到北京之后也比较喜欢徒步吧，然后在徒步的这个过程中确实看到有很多垃圾的问题，
然后觉得自己这个徒步之外还有富裕的这种体能呀，然后也有这种想法去尽自己所能去保护徒步路线，保护徒步路线上的这些自然美景吧。
所以你的第一次减垃圾的经历还记得吗？
第一次减垃圾大概是在18年吧，18年当时去河北的小舞台山，然后我记得是周末去的，周天下山的时候经过一个营地，
然后看到那个营地周围有很多的这个垃圾和这个小舞台山当时那个季节的美景是格格不入的，
就是很不理解这种乱人垃圾的行为，然后觉得都下山了嘛，觉得自己体能还可以吧，就顺便减了两袋垃圾带下山，对，那个算是第一次在户外减垃圾。
我觉得这个可能平常就是我们喜欢户外的人就是这种顺手把看到的垃圾这种带下山的行为是也会使有发生的，
但是你从一个看到了觉得很不爽，然后顺手把垃圾带下山，然后发展到自己成立一个户外组织，是中间是经历了什么呀？
那个时候可能18年或者疫情前玩户外的人还没有那么多，那个时候户外相对来说是一个比较专业的运动，
然后慢慢的就是走的路线也多了，然后可能有一段时间也一直在户外走嘛，然后就发现除了你我们进的京京街的这些路线很多其他地区的路线也有这种各种各样的垃圾，
然后大概是在19年吧，19年国庆的时候去了一下那个川西供导，然后反正那个时候在我的观念里面我认为这些什么高海拔的路线呀长距离的路线都是需要通过负重，
然后需要你有一定的体能，有一定的这种户外经验才能走进去的，但是当我去走到这个路线的时候，我看到的实际情况是有很多那种就是认知范围之外的垃圾，
比如说自治范河压，各种一次性育压这些，然后慢慢的了解到其实有很多当地的马队马帮，他们为了就是挣钱吧，
包括一些商业队，然后通过各种就是提供这种服务，然后降级了户外的门槛，让很多可能不是很专业的人或者是没有做好准备的人都能有机会到户外去，
但是他们的这些可能专业只是不够压户外理念，环保理念不够压，然后最后垃圾可能就都流到山里面了，
然后发现不只一条路线这样吧，就很多路线都有这种情况，然后那个时候我自己玩户外身边也有很多认识的玩户外的朋友就想着能不能通过这个资源吧，
然后去带动一下大家一块去做这件事情，反正我们都要去徒步嘛，然后就在徒步的这个过程中也去顺手去清理一下垃圾。
那你2020年一开始做这个活动的时候参与的人多吗？
我们大概是18号，好像是18号当时去三峰，我自己去测试了一下那个袋子，因为当时想做这个活动的时候其实考虑的还蛮多的，
因为山里面减垃圾跟可能城市里面减垃圾还不太一样，它有各种灌木呀，然后上坡下坡呀，就是袋子的这个大小容量，
然后袋子的结实度呀，包括提的这个长度各方面我可能当时都考虑了，然后当时去测试一下袋子，然后到20号吧，
然后我们就在三峰组织了第一期的活动，当时有30多个人参加应该是。
第一次能有这么多人就已经很不错了。
还行，反正觉得也蛮好的。
所以其实你从第一次活动就已经开始就用自己设计的这些专业的装备了。
当时好像第一次活动是大家自己带的袋子吧，我一样的。
然后后面每次在升级，一直在升级装备。
对，后面慢慢的我们就还是希望大家能记住守护赞这个组织这个品牌嘛，
然后也为了就是降低大家参加的门槛，
所以我们就开始准备这个专门的袋子呀，手套这些东西。
所以你们现在的装备有哪些呀，
除了袋子比如说像有没有夹子或者手套什么的之类的，你们的完整装备是什么？
我们现在提供的就是手套和袋子这两个基础的东西，
然后袋子的话以前是提供的，但是那个东西它毕竟太沉，而且成本会很高，
然后有很多这个喜欢参加的检拉机活动的人吧，
他可能并不都是这个专业的户外玩家体论什么的，
也没有专业的户外玩家那么好，
所以很多人他可能去参加活动的时候会把袋子当那个登山杖，
然后早期的时候这个准换率还是挺高的，然后我们慢慢的就不提供这个了，
然后就是大家根据自己的情况去准备吧，这个不是必须的，主要就是那个手套给袋子。
所以一般你们这个流程可能是，比如说去城的时候大家就途步看风景，
然后回城的时候大家开始捡垃圾这样对吗，这样比较可以节省体力，然后又把风景也看了。
我们都是从头捡到尾，这样子。
守护自然他的发起的处中就是为了捡垃圾嘛。
那现在你们每次活动大概有多少人参与呢？
现在我们的活动都限制在50人北京呢。
因为我知道好像民俄很难抢现在。
是的，我们常规活动都是，因为北京出去基本上都是大把车，
然后都按一个大把车的容量来安排吧。
而且也从这个户外路线的垃圾情况，
因为户外路线的垃圾还大多都是这种沿途有，
如果说一条路线没有太多太多垃圾的话，
我们放很多的这个志愿者进去其实意义不大。
后面的人他基本上也就纯粹的是跟着途步，
然后前面的人都见完了。
那目前你们去过的垃圾排名前三的路线是什么？
有南太行，还有河北那边有一个叫残谷陀。
然后北京周边像近海湖，这些垃圾都还是比较多的。
反正都是这种在户外路线上常看到的这些名字？
对,对。
感觉喜欢户外的人突然变多了，那你有觉得垃圾也变多了吗？
反正垃圾没有变少。
就是单看某一条路线可能觉得还挺干净，
然后或者是看我们对一条路线的清理好像没有以前那么频繁了，
可能以前隔两个月要去一次的，
然后现在可能有时候一年就去一次，
因为现在这个减垃圾的组织也蛮多的嘛。
所以有的路线可能别的组织减过了，
我们就不会再去浪费这种资源吧。
然后总体连终看下来的话，
反正垃圾的总量是没有减少的，整个户外。
那你们在山里减过最离谱的垃圾是什么？
各种各样的吧。
凉鞋，女士凉鞋完整的。
完整的？
对，基本上是全新的那种感觉，
然后你发推子，还有电的那种你发推子，
然后头盔，然后甚至冰套，胸罩，沙发，
什么什么，沙发？
对，沙发，还有一些电风扇，
然后各种什么油气筒啊，类似这样的。
感觉可以凑成一个故事了。
对，其实还蛮多的。
我其实参加过一次朋友组织的减垃圾活动，
就在北京那个，有一个古道叫什么了，
京西古道吧。
然后当时我们就是自己带了一个家里用的那种垃圾袋嘛。
我觉得我只花了五分钟就把那个袋子装满了。
是的，京西古道那边之前也是蛮多垃圾的，
因为那个古道早期的时候有垃圾桶吧，
然后也难度也不大，
很多人那种可能算是游客身份的也会去那边徒步，
然后看到有垃圾桶都开始往那边扔，
那边垃圾确实也挺多。
如果只是一些什么小的视频包装袋，
我觉得还好，
主要是有很多那个自热锅的那种东西，
那个东西特别占地。
自热锅也是我们这两年清理的户外垃圾里面，
比较多的。
对，其实我就想在节目里再跟大家提倡一下，
就是出去徒步不要带自热锅，
因为那个东西太污染环境了。
就是它体积又大，
它产生的那些汤汁和油又多，
首先你自己很难带下来，
然后其次你留在那对环境造成的污染也是极大的。
对，是的。
那你有走过，比如说金金剂，
觉得垃圾很少的，
环境维护的很好的线路吗？
延庆那边有一条路线叫联化碳。
我觉得那个路线的垃圾量还是非常少的。
是不是因为去的人少？
不，这两年去的人其实还是蛮多，
但是当年有一个算是营地吧，
然后他们在村里面做这种乡村振兴的，
然后正好也是挨着联化碳这个路线，
然后联化碳的路线他们从去年就开始修衫，
修衫各种生态的这种步道吧，
然后那边其实在修衫前修衫后，
我觉得都维护的还蛮好的，
因为经营营地的那个主理人，
他自己也很认可，
我很善良的理念，
所以他有时候带客人去山里面，
徒步的时候他也会顺手的去把垃圾带下山，
然后这个整个路线干净的话，
后续跟着人的人也少慢慢的，
他就形成了一个良心的循环吧，
对是的，
其实我那天刷短视频，
然后看到有一个户外博主，
就是那个户外宝马哥，
然后他发了一条视频，
还引发了一些小的讨论，
就是其实这个话题也是在整个这几年，
大家不断的提起的，
就是在户外到底能不能扔橘子皮，
就是你吃剩的什么玉米棒子之类的这种东西，
很多人看来，
就是这本身就是自然力部分吧，
那我把橘子皮扔到土里，
是不是他就变成了这个土壤，
什么肥料的一部分，
但是有一个问题，
就是大家可能没有想到的，
就是像刚才牧江提到的，
就是当你这个地方出现一丁点垃圾的时候，
他其实是形成了一个破窗效应，
有人看到这里有个橘子皮，
他就想，
哎，那是不是我就能随手把我这个小视频带扔在那里，
然后有人看到了小视频带和橘子皮，
那他就随手把困在水平扔在那里，
其实他就会从一个点发展成了一个面，
成了一个垃圾队，越来越多。
是的，是的，关于这个就是可降解垃圾能不能扔到户外，
这个网上讨论确实挺多的，
我觉得这是一个比较公共的一个话题，
但是讨论的这个每个人呢，
都是寄自己的经验呀，
寄自己所处的这个小环境来去，
去得出自己的结论，
其实这种降解的东西啊，
它是一个很复杂的过程，
并不是像我们这个，
就是上完厕所，
按一下这个马桶的这个冲水键就完事了，
它不是这样的，这样的一个快速的一个过程，
因为降解它其实，
跟海拔呀，温度呀，湿度呀，
以及这种机制的环境呀，人流量，
反正各种因素吧，都有关系都会影响它的降解的这个程度，
再一个就是刚才我们提到的，
如果说垃圾没有及时的消失的话，
那就会带来更多的这种，
这种后续的问题吧，
比如说这个世界污染呀，
破装效应呀，
甚至这个人受冲突，
这些东西，
所以我们还是尝到，
就是不属于这种自然界里面，
原本当地有的东西，
所有的人为带到自然里面的东西，
最好是带到这个城市里面，
带到垃圾桶里面去。
问题是，
我觉得你在户外看到满地的瓜子皮，
也会觉得很不舒服呀，
你在家刻瓜子的时候，
你不会把瓜子皮拖在地上，
那你就不应该在户外把瓜子皮拖在地上。
本身这个乱人垃圾，
它也确实是一个文明，
不文明的这个这个行为吧，
首先就不要去想它能不能降解这个事情。
对，是的，
那你们目前剪的垃圾排名前三的那个是什么？
这个矿泉水瓶，这个是最多的。
对对对，然后视频包装袋，
然后再就是这个刚才说的自热锅的这个盒子，
这些东西。
这三种塑料是最多的。
那目前你们的这个组织有几个人呀？
组织我当时发起的，
现在领队有三十多个，
然后志愿者的话，
大概有七千多人吧，社群志愿者。
哇，是个很庞大的组织。
还是有很多人愿意和想要参加到这种活动里面呢？
那你们的活动会有，会欢迎小孩参加吗？
四岁以上的可以。
起码能提得动带子。
对，能自己走，我觉得就OK。
其实更多的还是一个就是二如无染的教育吧，
可能对小朋友来说。
是的，是的，
因为我们这里面也有很多小朋友就是，
其实最小的时候四岁，
然后当时跟我们一块去天门山，
香山，然后现在他也八九岁了。
其实就是参加了不少活动，
然后我们也算是看着他长大的吧。
那你们在平常进山的过程中，
会亲眼目睹那些人随手乱丢垃圾，
然后会跟他们发生冲突吗？
也不发什么，
以前有过，以前有志愿者跟，
算是这个，
其他的人发生过冲突，
甚至进入这个派出所的去调解的。
因为我们的志愿者，
最近人群庞大嘛，
所以各种理念的人都有吧，
有的可能稍微极端一点的，
然后就会跟现场的人去讨论这个，
不要乱认的问题，
然后呢，
现场的有的人又觉得，
可能被说较了呀，
甚至刚才在讨论的有的人，
他就认为，
这个什么裹皮裹壳，
我觉得可以扔了，
甚至我觉得我抽烟，我抽完之后，
把烟头掐面了也不会引起火灾问题，
然后因为这些各种，
就是观念的不一致，
然后产生冲突的还是有的，
但是在后面我们的活动里面，
都会,
每次都会，
刻意的去强调这个冲突的问题，
就是我们志愿者只能做好自己的事情，
然后通过我们做的这个事情，
是可以潜移默化的去慢慢影响到别人的，
如果你直接简单粗暴的跟别人说，
这样这样做是不对的，
那还是容易产生这个冲突吧，
确实,
但是也很难，
我觉得这个心情，
就是我好不容易，
把这条步道，
可能垃圾简直嘻嘻啪啪，
清理干净了，
然后又有人，
可能就在我眼皮底下随手扔了，
或者是，
我清理完了之后，
过两天再回来一看，
又都扔满了垃圾，
就是你的这种心情，
是如何进行做调解的呢？
确实是，
经常都会有这种情况，
不管是别的志愿者，
还是我自己本人吧，
就会看到这种情况，
或者这种现象，
都会有这种心情不好的时候，
但是没办法呀，
你也改变不了别人，
只能,
就是尽自己所能去，
做好保护环境这件事情吧，
本来这个，
确实也是一个志愿的义务的嘛，
也不求大家能，
都能那个，
珍惜你的付出吧，
但是还是，
确实是有越来越多的人，
能看到你的付出，
能那个，
就是参与到这种活动里面来，
或者是，
能做到自己不扔垃圾。
那你觉得，
平常在你们活动的过程中，
或者是在组织的过程中，
最难的是哪个部分呀？
在组织的发展方面，
确实最难的还是这个，
可持续问题吧，
因为,
说起来是一个简单机，
好像是一个很简单的事情，
这个对于个人而言，
确实是这样的，
就是,
一双手套，
一个袋子，
是吧,
周末就可以去山里面，
简单机了，
但是对于一个组织来说，
它要做的事情，
和考虑的各方面的问题，
都是不一样的吧，
比如说，
你要去注册一个商标，
啊,
因为你不注册的话，
可能你经营的，
比如说，
这种理念，
或者品牌，
就会被别人，
就是从，
这个,
不违法的角度拿走了，
啊,
虽然它是这个，
这个,
可能不到的呀，
或者什么的，
但是没办法，
虽然你就会去注册商标，
就会涉及到，
呃,
公司的主体呀，
各种乱七八糟的东西，
那这些东西，
都是需要经费的，
那如果你，
你的一个组织的身份，
没有这些，
接近来源，
你要想把这个组织，
做得更好，
或者是，
跟上一层落的话，
是,
我觉得比较困难的。
确实,
一方面，
又是要，
公义的，
这么一个行为，
一方面，
你,
又要作为一个，
组织的，
发起人，
和负责人，
你要想要，
去给它，
维持它，
壮大它，
让它有，
更多的发展，
所以,
这中间，
其实是，
需要很大的付出，
有朋友说，
他可能也，
参加过，
某些的，
组织的，
减垃圾的活动吗？
他说,
刚开始，
减垃圾的时候，
很有成就感，
后来觉得，
怎么减都减不完，
甚至感到，
空虚,
和绝望，
那你有过，
这样的时刻吗？
我觉得，
每一个参加，
减垃圾，
或者是，
经常参加，
减垃圾活动的人，
都应该，
会有,
这种,
这种想法吧，
大家开始都觉得，
这个事情，
有些希望，
但是,
随着大家，
这个,
经常性的参与，
然后,
甚至像，
守护自然这边的，
这个,
我们这边的，
志愿者都是，
偏年轻化的，
然后,
大家也都，
非常的，
就是实干，
就不是说，
我们做一些，
表面的呀，
偏宣传的，
大家都是，
实实在在的，
去把这个垃圾，
清理走了，
那有的这个，
他们每次，
可能,
要扛十几公斤，
慢慢的升级，
就会开始疲倦，
甚至,
在扛垃圾的过程中，
有时候会觉得自己，
好像不是，
在做一些，
志愿服务的，
这种工作，
感觉,
变成了一种，
干体力活儿，
干这个，
所谓的，
专职环保的，
这种工作吧，
再就是，
做完这些，
体能,
体力活儿之后，
发现,
我下次来的时候，
这个路线的垃圾，
还是很多，
就觉得我自己，
做的事情，
是没有被，
这个,
真实的，
中下的，
这种环境下，
如果光靠，
志愿者，
去做这种事情，
光靠,
我们去呼吁，
到底,
有没有实际的意义，
是不是，
需要等，
相关的，
法律法规，
监权之后，
然后,
大家再去，
做一些，
辅助的事情，
反正都会有，
这种想法，
那你,
当时有过，
这种时刻的时候，
你是怎么，
怎么想通的呢，
怎么排解的呢？
我觉得，
都是当下的情绪，
过了之后，
到垃圾的时候，
还是觉得，
不希望它，
留在山里面，
还是想去，
去把它清理干净，
对，主要还是看不过去，
我觉得，
还有一个重灾区，
就是有一些景点，
它处于，
半野生，
不野生的那种，
你进去的时候，
它没有门票，
但是它会收你个，
什么十块钱的，
垃圾清理费，
然后,
很多人呢，
就觉得，
你都已经收我这个钱了，
那我就可以随手乱扔，
然后,
它就加剧了，
它的乱扔垃圾的，
这种行为，
在很多地方，
能看到，
但是其实那些人收了，
它可能就是村民，
自己拦了一下，
就是自己收的那个，
垃圾清理费，
他们也没有真的，
认真在清理这个垃圾，
就是这种，
看了以后，
也挺愤怒的，
对,
现在,
尤其是这个，
户外火了之后，
就是,
周末有很多人，
去的,
可能某条路线，
去,
去徒步嘛，
然后这个，
路线周边的村子，
也都,
想要接这个机会，
发展自己的，
这种经济吧，
然后也确实，
有一些这种，
简单粗暴的，
通过去，
收这个，
进山费，
然后垃圾处理费，
这种名义，
去南路收费的，
也有,
反正各种情况都有吧，
但是,
在我看来的话，
在户外环境，
还是,
呃,
我们一直提倡的，
大家要，
把垃圾，
自己带下山，
最好是，
带回城市，
带回到这种，
有更完善，
更科学的，
垃圾处理系统的地方，
因为,
垃圾在野外，
还有垃圾桶，
能不能扔到野外，
其实,
也要看，
回收的，
这个,
及时性，
如果说，
这些野外的垃圾，
回收不及时的话，
那就有可能，
带来,
我们一直讨论的，
这个,
严重的，
破装效应，
因为,
它的这个，
垃圾桶，
也要考虑这个，
人流量，
然后,
如果你没有及时清走，
扔到人又多，
甚至超出了，
这个,
垃圾桶的，
这个容量，
它还不愿意，
靠近垃圾桶，
就,
可能你的机密院，
就开始扔了，
它认为，
就是我叫了，
非用有人清走，
但是,
这些垃圾，
有可能，
就是,
被风刮走，
然后被这个，
动物,
物食,
甚至是，
被这些，
所谓的，
我要处理垃圾桶的，
这些,
回收系统的人，
它,
掩埋起来，
这些情况都有，
我们在，
实际的清理过程中，
不只发现过，
大家看起来，
就地掩埋，是吗？
对,
就是,
我收了费用，
或者是我没收费用，
但是,
我作为，
可能,
管理方，
比如说，
像,
我们刚才提到的，
京西古道，
或者是，
有一些，
北京周边的，
这种,
步道吧，
它,
不收费，
但是,
山上有垃圾桶，
那,
可能早期的时候，
或者是，
规划,
小小的，
管得那么好，
或者是，
认真的去管，
你可能，
今天扔了垃圾，
你下周，
或者是下个月，
去这个路线的时候，
看到是干净的，
你认为是，
清理走了，
但是垃圾，
可能只是，
藏在这个，
你看不到的地方，
这个,
是我们，
经常在户外，
遇到过的情况，
有很多，
在一些，
比如,
休息的娘亭，
附近,
灌木村里面，
偏你,
这个,
垃圾堆的，
这些都是，
这个,
回收系统的人，
并没有把垃圾，
运走,
他可能就，
藏在灌木里，
埋在这个，
土壤里面，
或者是，
丢到一些，
这个,
压壁下，
是,
我记得我去走，
那个,
胡跳侠的时候，
就见到过，
他是以，
一个垃圾桶，
为原心，
然后周围辐射了，
大概十米的，
垃圾堆，
就是,
可能最开始，
他是一个垃圾桶，
然后他就装满了，
后面的人，
他还是随手，
会把垃圾，
扔在他附近，
然后慢慢慢慢，
他就形成了一个，
就是,
因为没有人清理，
一个,
龐大的垃圾堆，
对，早期，
我们去，
洛克图布的时候，
呃,
当地的村民，
会每个团队，
或者甚至，
每一个，
呃,
露营的人，
都会收垃圾，
处理费，
然后,
你会看到，
整个营地周边，
确实把垃圾，
清理感觉了，
没有这个垃圾，
在周边，
寻找一下，
就会发现，
有的地方，
非常非常多的垃圾，
很多年的垃圾，
都全部堆在一块，
这个垃圾，
他们并没有真正的，
带走。
当地的村民，
他们也没有，
处理垃圾的能力，
和那个，
呃，知识，
对,
因为,
这个,
人群一多了之后，
产生垃圾量大，
靠那么一小，
一小部分人，
其实,
很难处理的，
更便捷的方式，
就是,
我觉得，
这个是，
成本最低，
最好的。
对,
我觉得，
得让,
每一个去户外的人，
有一个意识，
就是,
在这些地方，
没有义务给你，
设立垃圾桶，
你必须得把，
自己的垃圾，
带走。
对,
我觉得，
大家如果，
真的爱护自然，
都认为自己，
交到垃圾费，
是为了保护自然的话，
其实,
靠你自己是，
最靠得住的，
你靠别人，
可能,
最后这个垃圾，
他们处理，
垃圾的方式，
就是把它粉烧了，
对,
粉烧了，
或者是埋起来，
以前我们在，
北京的，
水圈沟，
然后,
就是,
像上级反映过，
这个垃圾问题，
然后,
他们确实处理了，
但是,
过了,
大概两年吧，
我们在去那边，
捡垃圾的时候，
意外发现，
垃圾都被埋起来了，
只是,
不让你看见了，
对,
然后,
你就认为，
这个问题解决了，
是的,
尽管,
捡到的垃圾，
都会给它，
呃,
怎么样处理呢？
嗯,
因为守护咱的，
这个,
目的,
或者目标，
还是,
呃,
優先把山上的垃圾，
带下山嘛，
然后,
嗯,
我们一般路线，
十公里，
从早上，
出发到，
结束也，
基本上，
都天黑了，
其实,
而且,
户外有很多，
这个山下的路线，
它是,
没有办法，
主要的，
发挥的作用，
就是,
把这种，
沿线的垃圾，
然后,
给带下山，
在会总的，
大袋子里面，
然后,
放到,
究竟的，
这种垃圾站，
因为,
在北京周边，
其实,
很多村子，
它都是有一个，
这个垃圾回收站的，
然后,
你把垃圾，
放到那个位置之后，
它,
比如说，
第二天，
就会有，
统一的，
这个垃圾车，
后续到这个处理吧。
嗯,
那你们有没有想过，
比如说把，
回收过的垃圾，
可以做成一些周边呢？
比如说，
可以带来一些引力，
能更好的支持，
你这个，
工艺组织？
是的,
我们以前，
有我考虑过，
比如说，
捡到的一些，
这种,
就是,
意想不到的垃圾，
做一些这种站，
然后,
也想过，
把一些像，
这个塑料品，
这些,
可回收再深的垃圾，
去做一些，
这种,
周边纪念品，
去做售卖，
不光是卖给，
这个,
参加过活动的，
志愿者，
当纪念品，
也可以卖给，
就是,
支持,
环保的，
这些,
全国各地的网友吧，
以我这样的想法，
但是,
这个东西，
它真正的，
执行起来，
还是挺繁瑣，
以及,
是会有一些，
这种,
成本的吧。
嗯,
就是,
以目前的经历，
来说,
还,
没办法去，
做这些事情。
嗯,
因为你，
还有本职工作，对吧，
所以,
你其实是在，
业余时间，在做这些，
对,
想法是挺好的，
那,
就你的观察，
你觉得，
户外,
乱人垃圾的，
都是什么人呢？
就是,
也不是说，
非得要点名，
但是,
因为,
从我们的角度，
去想,
可能,
包括,
平常我们在，
户外乱人垃圾，
的这种行为，
和现象，
感到非常的气愤，
那,
到底是什么人？
这种人，
他是真正的，
热爱户外的人吗？
怎么说呢？
我觉得，
人垃圾的人，
其实,
就是人垃圾的人，
他,
还真的，
不能分是，
游客呀，
然后,
普通的，
这些,
打卡的人呀，
或者是这个，
专业的，
这个,
户外人群，
都有,
真的都有，
那类似，
可能,
就是,
没有那么热爱户外的人，
其实,
人垃圾，
这两类人都有，
只是说，
这个,
比例多少的区别吧，
一般玩家的话，
他们,
可能,
就是,
缺乏,
经验吧，
不管是户外经验，
还是这个，
环保的，
这种意识，
大家的这个，
行钱,
准备,
不够充分的话，
那就更容易，
造成这个，
垃圾,
丢到山里面的行为，
因为,
捡垃圾的人，
就早期，
他们不参加，
这个,
捡垃圾的时候，
他们到山里面，
也会带自热锅，
因为,
他们不知道，
在户外，
是有,
这个,
户外,
专门用的，
这种,
清凉化的，
这些,
吹剧,
他就认为，
我想在户外，
吃可热的，
就只能用自热锅，
他可能，
也带了，
这个垃圾袋，
但是他不知道，
在山里面，
可能,
他平时用的，
走走走，
发现挂破了，
那就,
掉到山里面了，
对,
他如果参加过，
守护载案的活动，
可能就觉得，
哎,
你看,
守护载用的，
都是这种，
无仿布的袋子，
更耐挂，
更耐磨一些，
那他用这种袋子，
产生垃圾的，
这个概率就，
就少了，
这种,
是从一些，
算是叫普通玩家，
他,
因为缺乏经验，
准备不充分，
然后,
造成了这个，
丢垃圾的，
就注重这个，
这个重量，
我的负重，
他认为垃圾，
是没有价值的东西，
对我来说，
没有意义了，
没有价值了，
那我,
人垃圾也没有，
也不需要付出代价，
就,
就扔了，
仅此而已，
我觉得，
这个,
人垃圾的人，
都有吧，
反正,
不管是热爱的，
还是不热爱的，
其实都有，
不过你说到，
奇怪,
我确实，
走一些长线的时候，
经常能看到，
奇怪这种垃圾，
真正玩户外的人，
才会扔的，
因为普通打卡的人，
他是不会戴这种东西的嘛，
所以其实，
反而,
我经常看见，
奇怪这种垃圾，
对,
其实像平常，
参加跃跑比赛的时候，
然后也会看到，
因为有时候，
起跑的时候，
气温会比较低，
然后有些，
可能,
高手,
他会,
就是,
选择,
穿一些比较轻薄，
更便捷的衣服，
他就会用，
这种,
保温毯，
然后在起跑的时候，
想要保持，
自己的身体温度，
然后这样一便于，
他,
在开始跑的时候，
能,
轻装上阵，
那这些人，
他就会随手，
把保温毯，
丢在,
这个,
跑道上，
或者是跑到旁边的，
这种,
灌木,
草地,
树林里，
那你说，
这些人，
他是不是户外玩家，
那他可能真的，
运动表现是，
比,
我们普通人都要好的，
他也会，
经常参加，
这些,
越野的比赛，
什么态度呢，
那这,
这也真的是不好说，
对,
有很多，
这个,
越野跑的选手，
他们也会想着，
嗯,
这种赛事，
是会有，
这个,
可能,
赛事方去做回收的嘛，
嗯,
然后也会去丢，
但是现在，
我们其实看到，
很多,
赛事也，
在这个，
比赛前，
甚至强制的要求，
这种,
做好一些，
个人的环保行为吧，
嗯,
然后,
影响到你的成绩，
对,
我觉得现在，
也是在慢慢，
向好的发展，
因为都靠，
赛事方去做，
事后的这个，
回收的话，
我们刚才一直，
提过这个，
在野外，
如果回收不及时，
其实,
那这个垃圾，
就可能，
回收不回来了，
就会,
就会超出，
我们的这个，
可控范围类，
嗯,
对,
越野跑和马拉松，
还不太一样，
就越野跑，
你要回收垃圾，
太难了，
是的,
都是食物的，
饮料的包装，
可能,
徒步的过程中，
产生的大部分垃圾，
都是这一类，
那么,
你有没有一些，
tips,
比如说，
给徒步的人，
一些减少，
垃圾的，
路餐的建议呢？
总体来说，
这个户外，
目前,
尤其是，
在北京的话，
这种,
周末团，
或者是叫，
单天的活动，
还是,
嗯,
站主要的，
这一部分的，
嗯,
一个,
一个中午的路餐嘛，
其实路餐，
真的是，
越简单越好，
嗯,
我觉得就是，
遵循这个原则，
简单,
即是最好的，
一方面，
就是在那个，
大家去，
出发之前，
去准备这个，
这个,
路餐的时候，
省事,
省时间，
另外一个方面，
也可以，
尽可能的，
去减少，
垃圾的产生，
减少这个，
丢到山里面的，
可能性，
然后,
大家去准备的话，
就是三明治呀，
饭团呀，
面包呀，
火腿肠呀，
这些,
你都可以，
提前把包装，
都扭到家里面，
比如说，
你的这个面包，
那很多面包里面，
它是有一个，
这个,
这个叫干燥剂，
嗯,
或者是，
面包本身的，
这个包装，
那其实，
你是可以把这个，
面包拆开，
然后,
装到这个，
可重复，
使用到，
这种保险盒里面的，
因为,
有很多，
刚才我们提到的，
不管是，
哪部分的人群，
大家去扔垃圾的时候，
无非认为这个东西，
没有价值了，
对不对，我就扔了，
大家不可能，
去山里面涂过的时候，
把自己的这个，
登山杖呀，背包呀，
丢到山里面，
因为,
都是花钱买来的，
而且都是比较贵重的，
那,
那这种，
这种就是，
包装的这些东西，
其实你也可以，
换一个思路嘛，
比如说，
这个我们带的，
喝的水，
那你就用水别，
现在有很多，
这种,
专门的生产，
在水别的品牌，
你去买它的水别，
然后,
哪怕你是，
灌到这个，
瓶装的，
换钱水，
你也可以把这个，
瓶子,
松脚瓶子，
提前流到，
这个市区，
流到自己的，
这个家里面，
然后,
你带到山里面，
支持你的水别，
你喝完水之后，
你不可能把，
你的水别丢掉，
从,
从这种角度来讲，
就是,
食物也是一样的，
你把它，
装到这个，
可重复使用的，
保险盒里面，
让这个你的食物，
是保持新鲜的，
同时,
这个保险盒，
本身的形状，
它还可以防止这个，
防止你的食物被挤压，
其实,
我觉得是一个，
蛮,
蛮友好的一个行为吧，
其实,
我们能做的东西都，
有很多，
而且也很简单，
关键在于，
你愿不愿意去，
做这件事情？
嗯,
其实就是多了一步，
就是,
你尽量避免把，
这种,
一次性的东西，
带到自然里去，
然后我觉得，
是不是还有一点，
就是,
尽量带去自然的东西，
你少带那些，
需要留下汤汤水水，
或者是油的东西，
你可能尽量带一些，
像这种，
比如说，
像三明治，
或者饭团，
你都可以给它，
完全消耗掉的，
这种路餐，
是的,
就是带这种，
消耗完了，
这个就，
呃,
举一个，
带水果的例子吧，
可能大家就更容易理解，
比如说，
你尽量带一些，
吃完不产生，
这个裹皮裹盒的，
然后少带那种裹皮裹盒，
要去处理的吧，
嗯,
就西瓜这种，
就是算，
对呀,
西瓜这种，
就是比较麻烦，
当然你要是带，
比如说这个，
黄瓜呀，
然后,
西红柿呀，
这一类的，
就相对来说好一些，
就带什么，
苹果呀，
然后西瓜这些，
我觉得更可取吧，
因为你在山上，
带的时间，
其实不成，
你想吃，
什么,
自热锅，
火锅这些，
这些各种，
你喜欢的水果，
其实都可以到山下去，
去吃嘛，
对,是,
而且那种，
很多油，
和辣椒的那种汤，
倒在野外的话，
是会对植贝产生影响的，
就是破坏植贝，
其实大家，
呃,
去香港，
麦里豪金图播的话，
这种感受会更深，
呃,
因为我觉得内地的这种，
山里面，
其实还是，
很少能见到，
一些大型的，
这种野生动物的，
那如果说，
我们把，
食物倒到，
一些,
比如山里面，
认为,
没有什么影响的，
呃,
但是你换一个环境，
那就不一样了，
比如说，
这个麦里豪金，
我之前去图播的时候，
确实,
有很多这个，
野州的问题，
他们,
基本上都是，
闻着这个味道，
然后来靠近，
可能你的路营区，
靠近,
就是大家休息的地方，
那就会，
有这种潜在的，
这个人受冲突的风险，
其实对于，
不管对于这个图播者来说，
甚至说，
对这个野生动物来说，
都是不安全的，
我觉得，
就还是，
尽量不要留到山里面吧。
而且香港，
是真的会罚款的，
我觉得这一点，
非常好，对。
如果大家去，
呃,
河北,
北宁山，
就是在，
在这个北京周边，
这个户外圈里面，
比较火的一条路线，
去那边路营的话，
这种对动，
就垃圾对动物的影响，
的这个现象，
还是比较明显的，
呃,
因为那边，
它好像有一种，
黑色的大鸟，
不知是叫什么，
然后大家这个，
周六去路营的时候，
其实还好，
但是,
这个鸟会，
准时的，
在周日的早上出现，
因为,
他们已经习惯了，
习惯知道，
大家周日的早上，
要开始拔营了，
拔营就会，
产生很多，
很多这个，
呃,
食物的垃圾，
他们就会来，
来吃,
就是这个已经，
这个,
这个习惯了，
嗯,
包括在，
在河北，
其实有很多这个，
到夏天嘛，
大家有很多去路营的，
这个,
这个情况，
呃,
有很多那个，
当地人放暮的，
这些牛啊，
然后羊啊，
其实,
都会跑到，
路营的地方，
然后之前，
也有的人，
第二天早上，
那个,
晚上路营的时候，
这个,
这个用餐的这些，
呃，餐具没收的，
第二天早上就，
可能,
被这个，
流氧给裁扁的，
这些过晚漂盆，
呃,
我觉得这个，
裁扁,
它本身对，
对于个人来说，
是一种，
呃,
装备的损失吧，
但其实，
更重要的，
还有一个过程就是，
呃,
我们在野外，
制造这些垃圾，
然后,
就是,
把这些动物吸引过来的话，
其实,
对于我们的，
这个生命安全，
也是有一个，
这种,
威胁的吧，
嗯,
有些人，
其实这个，
这个女孩子，
他们,
这个,
可能在帐篷里面，
睡觉,
突然听到有牛过来了，
就会有，
发出各种，
被,
被惊吓到的，
这种,
喊声叫声，
其实,
会,
刺激到动物，
之前在冰山那样，
其实,
还见过一次，
真的是，
比较危险的一个，
行为,
就是,
就是这个，
牛群,
然后,
在大家的，
这个,
还是比较危险的，
嗯,
我看你们也，
其实在大力推广，
那个,
户外无痕的，
讲师培训，
对吗,
嗯,对,
所以,
可不可以给我们，
大家,
也聊一下，
到底什么是LNT，
然后,
如果普通人，
要做到无痕的话，
最难的，
会是哪一条，
嗯,
LNT呢,
其实,
它也有很多年了，
最早,
还是,
就是,
美国那边发起的嘛，
它,
户外或者叫，
无痕山陵，
嗯,
它就是，
是,
美国那边发起的，
意中,
这个,
户外生活方式吧，
它的目的呢，
就是,
倡导人们，
在自然中活动的时候呢，
去,
关注自然，
并且,
这个,
身体力行的，
去保护，
当地的自然环境，
然后,
最小化对自然的，
冲击,
嗯,
然后,
我觉得普通人，
其实,
要做,
这个,
无痕,
最难的就是，
我们,
刚才一直聊的，
这个,
充分的，
新鲜准备，
嗯,
如果,
大家能，
花时间，
花心思，
去做好，
这个,
充分的准备的话，
就很,
很自然的，
就能,
减少这个垃圾产生。
哎，那如果，
普通人，
我也想学，
这个,
接受这种培训的话，
大概需要多长时间呢，
或者是，
它是一个，
一个过程，
这个,
叫,
业余,
或者叫，
休闲板块，
嗯,
休闲的，
这种,
其实,
我们,
就简单的，
聊个,
十来分钟，
三十分钟，
甚至,
一天,
嗯,
大家了解，
它的一些，
这个,
算是,
它里面有，
其他,
嗯,
原则,
然后,
了解到，
它是怎么一回事，
理解它，
俗谅的，
去掌握，
在野外，
通过那些，
技巧,
那些方式，
可以尽可能的，
减少这个，
对环境的冲击，
因为,
我们,
说到,
无痕,
户外其实，
不光是，
这个,
我们看到的，
或者是，
普通人理解的，
这个垃圾污染，
嗯,
它比如说，
对这个，
地表的损害呀，
然后,
嗯,
对动植物的，
伤害呀，
甚至说，
一个,
游客的，
这些影响，
都是无痕，
里面的一些，
这个,
犯仇吧，
都是应该考虑的，
对,
就比如说，
你在户外的时候，
攻放音乐，
这个其实，
就是违反了，
Leave No Trace,。
LNT的,
里面,
对,
它里面也提到过，
就是,
这个,
追踪其它的，
旅行者嘛，
因为,
大自然是大家的，
就是,
我们去，
去到大自然里面，
还是要，
也去,
为所欲为。
所以,
处理垃圾，
只是其中的一部分，
然后,
还有一部分，
可能是，
比如说，
你渣营的时候，
应该要选择什么样的地方，
可能对地表的，
环境破坏更小，
或者你，
拔营的时候，
应该怎么做呀，
就,
也有很多，
类似这样的知识，
对吗?
对,
其实,
我们在户外的，
任何的行为，
我们都要考虑，
做完之后，
对这个，
这个,
影响到这个，
这个程度，
以及影响完之后，
它的恢复程度吧，
如果说，
我们,
就是,
到这个地方之后，
对它原始的，
这个,
情况,
或者是，
原始的样子，
改变得比较大，
甚至它的恢复比较慢的话，
那我们就，
就要去，
避免这样的行为，
嗯,
包括,
比如说，
现在有的人去，
去摘花呀，
对,
生活呀，
去,
挖各种，
什么,
都是,
都是不倡导的，
所以其实，
我们根本没有办法，
真的做到无痕，
只是尽量的，
减少它的痕迹，
对,
所以,
LNT,
讨论的时候，
很多人就很忌惮说，
那如果都按LNT的话，
就最好，
就不要到户外，
其实LNT,
它是非常欢迎，
大家到，
大自然里面去了，
但是呢，
就是,
它提供了，
七条这个，
原则,
去覆盖到，
我们在户外的，
各种场景，
我们尽可能的，
去,
除了,
关注我们自己的这个，
我们想看到风泥之外，
我们也要去，
呃,
这个,
干同身受的，
去关注自然，
去,
去关注其他人吧，
然后,
呃,
最小话，
对这个，
我们去到的这个，
这个地方的，
一些这种，
呃,
冲击,
它并不是说，
就是绝对的无痕，
但是我们是可以，
控制自己的行为，
去做好，
这些充分的行情，
准,
准备,
本可以避免的，
这种影响的，
比如说，
这个,
我们刚才提到的，
生活,
可以生活，
那你要分这个，
时间段，
比如说这个，
防火漆，
那就不能生活，
这个是原则问题，
那如果说，
过了防火漆，
我们生活的时候，
就要保证，
呃,
这个,
火,
火灾的时候，
人必须得，
管控好你的这个，
火源,
甚至,
比如说，
我们可以，
这个,
生活还是蛮好的，
你去带一个分火台，
比你直接，
在草地上，
去生活好的毒物，
那这些东西，
你是完全，
可以提前去，
去做好准备的，
如果说你，
你不愿意去，
做好这些准备，
那最终就是，
还你来，
替你承担这些，
这些行为，
所以这个培训，
还有时间的部分，
是真的要去到户外，对吗？
对,
它的这个，
就是,
专业的，
这一个部分，
它就是，
讲究的是，
两天一夜的，
这种野外的时间，
会让你在户外去，
比如说去，
怎么去处理垃圾，
然后去，
怎么去照营地，
怎么去，
比如说，
把你的食物，
调起来，
避免,
避免就是，
这个吸引的动物，
然后,
比如说，
我们去讨论，
户外的哪些，
这种地质，
比如它有草殿呀，
有这个湿地呀，
有长城呀，
是怎么去走的，
都可以在这个，
在这个课程里面，
了解到深入的，
去了解。
那这个也挺有意思的，
我觉得，
如果对户外，
感兴趣的朋友，
也可以参加一下，
这种培训。
应该在，
这些大城市，
都会有，
相关的这些活动，
大家都可以，
关注一下。
对于我们都，
听有的这些，
户外爱好者来说的话，
就是,
如果他们，
也想在，
平常自己，
可能去到户外的时候，
做一些，
理所能及的事情，
来去,
保护自然，
或者是，
减一些垃圾回来，
你有什么建议吗？
就是有什么，
比如说，
他们可以，
配备了一些，
基础的，
工具。
就是,
我觉得减垃圾，
很多人讨论，
他就是，
可能你减了，
别人认识，
没有意义的，
但是我觉得，
减垃圾，
其实是一个，
非常有意义的，
一件事情，
它是一个，
最直接的能，
就是,
保护环境的，
一个行为，
然后是，
门槛最低的，
这种行为，
然后,
门槛里面，
去参与，
做一些，
这种,
逆所人际的事情，
就,
准备一个，
撑手的，
这个,
折叠的垃圾夹子，
也好到，
好,
装的包里面，
然后再，
准备一个，
刚才我们说的，
这种,
结实的，
无妨不带，
这两个东西，
两件套，
我觉得，
就,
就可以了，
最基础的，
就可以，
在你下山的时候，
在你觉得，
我们把宽天水瓶卖了，
买一根冰棍，
我觉得，
最后,
共将能不能，
就是,
对我们的听友，
说一句话，
就是,
比如说，
像他们即将去到户外，
或者是，
准备开启，
他们的，
第一次户外，
活动的人，
你有什么建议吗？
建议,
就是,
请把垃圾带下山，
然后,
做一个负责任的户外人，
简单直接，
是,
对自然负责，
也是对自己负责，
是的，是的，
因为,
还是希望，
每个人都能，
自觉的去爱护环境嘛，
就是,
人人参与，
我们这个参与，
不仅是说，
参与到，
像守护在组织的，
这种,
建垃圾的活动里面来，
就是,
你参与不认，
甚至参与宣传，
他也是一种参与，
人人参与，
自觉爱护，
人人受益，
这也是我们，
一直喊的口号吧，
我们怎么才能，
找到,
守护自然的活动呢？
我们的活动，
都在,
我们自己的，
小程序上报名，
然后,
我们也会把这个，
活动发到，
公众号上，
然后,
大家也可以，
通过公众号去了解，
然后,
或者是，
加入我们的社群，
我们会在，
社群里面去同步，
所以,
大家就可以，
直接在，
微信上，
搜,
守护自然，
这四个字，
手,
是双手的手，
是的,
然后,
可以,
搜索一下，
然后,
可以参与一下，
这个活动，
然后,
希望,
守护自然的活动，
也能,
开展到，
更多其他的城市，
是的,
欢迎大家，
嗯,
好的,
那,
今天,
先这样了，
谢谢牧家，
好的，好的，
好的,
谢谢你们，
好,
拜拜,